that they could take KF in a matter of
days they
miscalculated the determination of the
Ukrainian people and they underestimated
the resolve of the European Union and
the International
Community Ukraine has inspired and
continues to inspire the
world a few weeks after the initial
Invasion I spoke in the name of the
members of this European Parliament in
KF in front of the Hof arada and besides
president zalinski I made a promise on
behalf of all of us that we would stand
with Ukraine and its people for as long
as it takes in the past two years Europe
has kept that promise we will keep that
promise still our political economic
military Financial humanitarian and
diplomatic support has remained
steadfast the European Union is the
largest financial supporter of Ukraine
with 88 billion EUR um provided so far
we are ramping up our EU defense
Industries production capacity to
provide Ukraine with over 1 million
artillery rounds by the end of the year
an agreement on the additional 50
billion e Ukraine facility pending
agreement on the multiannual financial
framework was also reached last night
fun fing that is crucial for Ukraine
survival recovery and
reconstruction we know the sacrifice
that the Ukrainian people are enduring
we know they endure it for their sake
and for all of Europe for our collective
security for our shared values for our
way of life the European Parliament was
the first to call for Ukraine to receive
EU candidate status and we were the
strongest advoc vate for EU accession
negotiations to start last year because
we know that Ukraine's place is within
our
Union as we enter the third year of
Russia's war of aggression on Ukraine I
want to use this moment to renew this
promise that we made to the Ukrainian
people we are with you and we will re
remain with you Slava
ukraini
I give the floor now to the council to
the minister for foreign affairs
European Affairs and trade um and
federal culture institutions Minister
hajib Madame the president of the
parliament Madame the president of the
commission dear
commissioner honorable member of the
parliament the passionate debate we just
had is certainly linked to the fact that
we are celebrating and approaching to
this very very sad
anniversary indeed almost two years ago
Russia driven by the anachronistic urge
to redraw to redefine maybe the map of
Europe to satisfy its expansionist
Ambitions launch a fullscale military
aggression against Tran Ukraine bringing
the war back to Europe and let us
remember that Russia's aggression
against Ukraine is a clear violation of
the charter of the United Nations and
the fundamental principles of
international law for almost two years
it has been causing enormous human
suffering in Ukraine and causing our
exacerbating Global crisis inflicting
conable damage on the global economy
this war is today one of the main main
threats to peace and stability on our
continent and Far Beyond in the face of
this immense challenge Europe has shown
unity and
determination since day one the European
Council has provided strategic guidance
for the European Union's response and
taken decisive action the EU has just
strongly come down Russian aggression
and played a fun FAL role in effort to
isolate Russia on the international
stage in addition to unwavering
political support the European Union led
by its member states has provided an
extraordinary level of humanitarian
Financial economic and Military Support
to Ukraine and let me elaborate one of
the main aspects of this unprecedented
effort the both
I must emphasize that our assistance to
Ukraine is not only continuing it is
also increasing as president charl
Michelle has just said last week an
extraordinary European Council gave the
green light to additional assistance to
Ukraine to the tune of 50 billion Euro
for the period 2024 to 2027 thanks to
the Ukraine facility it is right now
vital to finalize this package which
allows for stable long-term assistance
to Ukraine and I thank the European
Parliament for its constructive work in
uh the trialogue which led to an
agreement in principle last night this
is an
agreement which
uh uh puts as long as it takes into
practice and helps to secure a future
for Ukraine and its uh uh population
there is 31
billion in budget support and
humanitarian Aid and
25 billion in military assistance and uh
we have increased humanitarian
assistance and civil protection
assistance uh which is benefiting 10
million people in Ukraine we have also
received Leed on our territory more than
4 million Ukrainian refugees with their
protection extended to March 2025
following a unanimous decision by the
member states in October of last year
this
uh
assistance has uh some consequences and
I appreciate the solidarity corridors
which we should keep and which we should
improve to to uh guarantee continued
export of Ukrainian grain and
agricultural products in order to lessen
the risk of famine all of our energy
today and tomorrow must be Center
centered on our uh Unity our
longterm uh cohesion and the
uh
the opening of um accession negotiations
with Ukraine is a very important signal
both to Ukraine and uh Russia as far as
the European Union is concerned Europe
Ukraine's accession to the EU is only a
matter of time and the clock is ticking
as we assist Ukraine we continue to
weaken Russia by means of sanctions
we're hoping to finalize a a 13th
package of sanctions on the symbolic
date of 24th of February 20
24 Council has used the European peace
facility to deliver 5.6 billion Euro in
assistance in the form of military
equipment to Ukraine we need to speed up
the delivery of Munitions and missile in
order to ensure that uh Ukraine gets a
million 105 55 mm shells from us as soon
as
possible we're only on 524,000 that's
not what we promised and we need to do
better the European Union and the member
states are working closely with Ukraine
and a very large number of countries who
are seeking a just and Global Peace
under the the egis of the United Nations
we support the Ukrainian peace formula
and we're ready to work for peace we're
ready to cooperate in the summit for
peace to work on the Ukrainian uh peace
plan put forward by President zalinski
the European Union remains utterly uh
determined our determination must be
unwavering the future of Ukraine and the
future of Europe depends on it thank
[Applause]
you thank you Minister I now turn to the
president of the commission Osa ferion
go ahead
Madam Mr President Madame Minister
honorable
members in any fight it is always the
site fighting for something that has a
higher power on its
side it is the one who believes in what
they are fighting for that will
sacrifice and do what it takes to
Prevail and conversely it is the site
who fights against something that will
always be scared scared to lose scared
to think of the future scared to speak
out two years ago Putin and Russia
started a war against something a war
against Ukraine and its territory
but also against the people and a nation
with an Iron Will and hope for the
future against their European
aspirations against the values they
share with us and quite simply against
both modern reality and the strong tides
of European
history and in doing so Putin started a
fight against all of us against Freedom
self-determination and Democratic de
democracy at Large against everything
that we have stood for over 70 years
Ukraine has proven the power of a nation
and a people fighting for something for
themselves first and foremost but also
for us and for everything that we
believe in Freedom democracy rights and
aspirations some were surprised by
Ukraine's heroic action but no one
should have been surprised that when
faced with oppression subjugation and
tyranny they chose
resistance and that is why honorable
members I remain just as convinced of
one simple fact today then I was two
years ago standing in front of you and
that is that Ukraine will prevail and
that Europe will stand with Ukraine
every step of the
way
honorable members we have spoken in
great detail over the last two years on
the eu's historic and massive support
for Ukraine be it military Financial or
human be it on sanctions security or the
single Market be it on the historic path
of Ukraine to our Union that this house
has been such a strong supporter
of but today on this point
anniversary debate it is a time to look
deeper at how we have got there and
where we must go the starting point is
that Ukraine and Europe have shown that
we are willing to fight and pay the
ultimate price for the things that we
believe in and this was one of Putin's
greatest miscalculations in that month
of February as he amassed troops on the
border and planned a quick lightning
strike on
ke Mr Putin you made this mistake
because you cannot understand what
drives a human Spirit when it is free to
think Dream create and prosper nor can
you understand because you cannot bear
to accept that a human desire for
Freedom will always win and honorable
members Putin cannot understand that if
you give people a choice they choose
Liberty once and for
all and in Ukraine's case they fight for
Liberation he cannot understand that the
fight of the Ukrainian is different to
the fight of a Russian soldier whose
lives Putin has callously churned for a
past long gone and a future that could
never
exist Ukraine's sacrifice is the
opposite why do they fight because they
are battling toiling for something
existential and inherent to The Human
Condition this is why Ukraine's will is
not just stronger than Russia's it is
fundamentally different in nature and in
character and this is what Putin will
never comprehend about us this is why
his invasion was not just morally but
also strategically wrong he cannot
understand freedom and why we fight for
it because his only instinct is to crush
what he
fears and this explain what has happened
in the last two years instead of
toppling ke dividing the European Union
and weaking NATO the exact oppos
opposite has happened on each and every
count with the support of the European
Union and our
allies Ukraine has not only held firm
against a bigger country a bigger Army
and a bigger
economy but it has retaken more than
half of the territory that Russia
occupied from the start of this
conflict they have knocked back Russian
offensives last winter and are doing the
same
now and this inum itable spirit is what
we have to keep in mind here in Europe
and right across the Democratic world at
this juncture of the war there's no time
for wavering there's no time for Naval
gazing the message Europe sent at last
week's European Council was crystal
clear and let me repeat it here Europe
will be at Ukraine's side for every
single day of this war and for every
single single day
thereafter honorable
members up our momentum to support
Ukraine and to protect our own
future that means thinking about
reconstruction about security
commitments about strengthening the
International System to avoid any
repeats or
reruns it also means continuing to
support Ukraine and everyone way we can
take Military
Support so far we have trained over
40,000 Ukrainian soldiers our Union and
member states have mobilized 28 billion
euros worth of military
equipment the European Defense industry
has increased its production capacity
for ammunition by
40% we will have delivered over half a
million rounds of artillery shells by
next month more than 1 million by the
end of the year
but this is certainly not
enough not only must we accelerate the
delivery of ammunition to
Ukraine as we look to the future we must
think of Ukraine's defense capabilities
as part of our defense capabilities we
must think of Ukraine's defense industry
as part of our own defense industry and
this is why we have involved Ukraine in
the
preparations of our own defense
industrial strategy it is a first step
which should lead to integrating Ukraine
in some of our defense programs with the
agreement of the European Parliament and
Council where
necessary this would not only help us
cater for Ukraine's defense needs it
will also encourage convergence and
Joint planning between our militaries
and defense Industries
Ukraine is a future member of our
European Union so it must get much
closer to us also in the field of
defense and this leads me to my third
and last point on Ukraine's path towards
our
Union the contrast with just 10 years
ago couldn't be
starer back then a pro-russia regime in
Ukraine was passing authoritarian laws
and killing protesters on the
streets
today this country has just given itself
new legislation to expand National
minority rights to improve the judicial
system and to ensure checks and balances
on
Power and this is what led us to
launching the accession
negotiations and this progress is
happening not not only because Europe is
asking for it this is the Deep desire of
the people of Ukraine Ukraine is Europe
because you Europe is in the hearts and
in the minds of ukrainians and soon
enough Ukraine will also be in our
Union honorable
members the anniversary that we marked
today is a tragic loss of human lives
and suffering and it is all the more
tragic as we know there will be more
pain and more suffering ahead we know
how much is at stake here for those in
Ukraine and also for the rest of
Europe Putin's fantasy and fabricated
war and Ukraine's heroic resistance has
reminded us
here that our freedoms and our democracy
are worth fighting for it so today we
pay tribute to those who are fighting
and we pay tribute to those who paid the
ultimate sacrifice in fighting for
something Slava
Ukraine thank you very much commission
president ferion and the first speaker
is Miss rasa yavich
please first of all thank you Madame
President for your strong
leadership Ukraine has shown a miracle
let's remember the first weeks how many
here believed that Ukraine would stop
the Russians at Kiev two years of this
war have also shown a miracle of
European Unity we know what we have
already done by standing together today
we have to talk and agree on what is
needed to win this war war first of all
the front needs even more support now
today this particular
minute second we must believe that we
can win this war we the Democratic world
are many times stronger than Russia the
economic power is
incomparable however the EU wide support
to Ukraine is only zero
0.075% of GDP per
year is it really an indicator that
shows our understanding of Europe's
existential War third we must not be
afraid of Russia just as the ukrainians
Are Not Afraid we must not be afraid of
Putin's blackmail and the defeat of his
regime Putin must lose fourth we need a
comprehensive Ive plan for the victory
of Ukraine this requires a vast
development of the EU defense industry
now is the time for the European Union
to get its act together on security a
defense Union is needed as never before
but I see such Union only together with
Ukraine with Ukraine in EU and in NATO
with its Army which is clearly the
strongest army in in Europe today the
victory of Ukraine will be the victory
of the whole Europe only Victory can
solve the historic eastern dilemma in
Europe Slava Ukraine Long Live
Europe thank you very much dear
colleague next speaker is Mr Pedro
markes
please thank you president Madame
President of the commission Council
colleagues
two years of this war more than 700 days
of suffering in Ukraine in each of these
days people were killed children lost
their F lives or their parents families
were destroyed by the brutal attacks of
Russia in each of this SE more than 700
days the brave Ukrainian people stood
against one of the most powerful armies
in the world showing their courage and
the
will but make no mistake courage and
determination can only do so much we
know that ukrainians need the ammunition
and they need the financial support to
win the war the Ukraine facility is long
overdue and Minister the mff review is
still not there we should have come to
this moment proclaiming that we are with
the ukrainians in every single day of
the war with an agreement on the mff
review and the money is still not there
so I please ask you to the council to
the presidency of the council there's a
message that needs to to be clear
trialogues are not monologues this
Parliament does not accept this idea on
economic governance on the mff review
that the trialogue is simply a monologue
so please bring back that message
because we need an agreement we need
rapidly to have an agreement to support
the ukrainians so that our proclamations
are followed by the money that we have
promised them and that is still lacking
let us deliver on this fight for liberty
let us agree rapidly on on our support
to Ukraine thank you thank you very much
Mr Marquez next speaker is Mr patrias
asri avitus
Please Mr chair Madam president
commissioner Madam Minister dear
colleagues a day before I spoke with a
colleague in Ukraine who shared
following
observations I quote only a strong
Europe with strong defense capabilities
can stop Russia from continuing on its
war path the war in Ukraine only gives
us Europeans time to properly prepare
Russian Society has been enslaved by
Putin regimes and is part of the war
machine it is therefore important that
Europe's security challenges are
properly understood by our citizens
especially by the young people who will
continue the fight against Eastern
totalitarism end of
quote 2 years into the brutal war in
Ukraine my friends observations sound
like a clear Manifesto for Europe
calling for solutions to be fully
implemented yesterday we concluded
trialog negotiations on Ukraine's
facility but the amount of our support
for Ukraine needs to be
multiplied so must European Defense
capabilities only in this way can the
threat to Europeans from Russian fascism
be averted slav Ukrainian Europeans
thank
you thank you very much Mr
austrii next speaker is Miss
Viola thank you
president Madame President of the
commission colleagues first of all we
said uh Ukraine would fall in two days
after two years the country is still
there for too long peace in this
continent has considered to be a given
that changed in February
2022 we we're reminded that peace is
based on military strength to defend us
and our allies since the start of the
invasion the Ukraine has won back uh the
Black Sea and uh ship routs uh we have
um Russian ships hiding in the Black Sea
because they're afraid of Ukrainian
drones for this uh fight for our freedom
Ukraine is paying a high
price Putin is is sending murderers out
of the prisoners out of the prisons
sending to the front uh Ukraine is
losing its best people every death is
too much this year Ukraine will get back
its uh airspace so that Russians can't
be terrorizing children in their sleep
but Ukraine can't do any of that without
our help every time if Washington doubts
uh Russia steps up its attack every time
when Berlin wobbles uh the Russians fire
more Rockets every time Orban blocks a
Aid more Ukraine's Ukrainian children
are deported and
killed nothing encourages the Russians
as much much as our weakness if Ukraine
Falls uh UK EU member states are the
next next on the
list Putin um likes nothing more than
our weakness and uh doubts the other
thing uh which separates us and the
threat are um the courage of the
ukrainians so the accession of Ukraine
isn't just some value it's uh in our own
security
interest we say as long as it takes
but this
means to give what is necessary so that
as long as it
takes doesn't take two more years thank
you very
much thank you very
much Miss Ana the next
speaker president ladies and
gentlemen in order to
survive
in order to have the advantage of the
West collectively both militarily and
economically we must support Ukraine
because it's bleeding and fighting in
our name it needs to be done now
unconditionally without pretending
things without treaties being changed
the budget being changed small member
states being blackmailed
what we
need is political will will which will
uh overcome anything and everything well
I have little hope for that but hope
dies last so perhaps I will see positive
results thank you mer
Madame thank you Madame F then we have
mrul
next thank you president the situation
in Ukraine deserves all our attention
however it should not lead to situations
which are detrimental to our own
Nationals um integrating Ukraine in the
EU would pose a threat to our farmers in
France and there are particular dangers
there since the start of the conflict
the EU has seeded to all Ukrainian
demands particularly when it comes to
free access for their poultry and
cereals to European markets and we've
sacrificed our own
Farmers uh the most fervent supporters
of Ukraine such as Poland have had to
put up barriers against the entry of
Ukrainian Cals given the deadly threat
that that has posed to their own
agriculture in
2018 Ukraine was the fifth largest maze
producer and the eighth largest wheat
producer in the world this is a threat
to our producers Ukrainian
producers
um posting their W in Europe can cause
their European and Ukrainian Goods to
reach all over the
world 5,000 tons of poultry arrive in
Europe every year priced four times
lower than production in France
Ukrainian producers do not respect our
standards and they can be
found in our distribution
chains M and his cronies in Paris claim
to defend our
agriculture but next June this Customs
exemption will inspire we have to ensure
the survival of French and
European
Agriculture and we will see who will
vote for what thank
you the next speaker is Miss
de thank you very much
president second two years that's how
long the war has been going on in
Ukraine and you think that uh in every
debate here you think that
U that all you're talking about is
battlefields and weapons but War has its
facts it's evident that the offense in
the offense in Ukraine has failed but
nonetheless you're calling for weapons
has the Putin
regime
it has the blood of Ukrainian children
on his hands Miss feline and Mr Biden
and Mr
Johnson they don't have Clean Hands
either because there were negotiations
for a ceasefire Mr zalinski stood here
at the F at the start and was in favor
of a ceasefire NATO said keep fighting
you're fighting for our
freedom and that is
cynicism why don't you let people in why
why do you let you people in Ukraine die
for your freedom and your geopolitical
interest and saying that tell your story
about people being attacked no the men
in Ukraine don't have
freedom to withdraw from war the women
and children who are afraid of their
families don't have a the freedom to
withdraw from the wall do something for
peace that is solidarity that is human
rights that is freedom
war is never Freedom de thanks Mrs deel
Calo thank you president two years
colleagues 24 months of bombs Terror
innocent people suffering just to
satisfy a tyrannical criminal regime
it's a moral duty for us to Rally our
forces uh to to defend them but also
it's an existential question for the
future of the EU thank you for those
clear strong expressions of commitment
as felion this is what we need the five
billion Euro increase for the European
peace facility should be uh uh deployed
now we need it now to get Munitions to
the front all those frozen assets should
be transferred to ke to help the
resistance
now we've seen what Victor Orban wanted
to do article 7 uh whatever means we
have at our disposal need to be used now
our Union has to defend all Europeans
Putin should see that we will not uh
hesitate we will defend the sovereignty
and freedom of Ukraine with all of our
strength and very soon Ukraine Ukraine
will be the 28th memb state there is no
uh Ukraine without the EU there's no EU
without the Ukraine either Slava Ukraine
we are running a bit late dear
colleagues so I ask you to respect the
allocated speaking time next speaker is
Mr Michel Gala uh president colleagues
shanov ukrain 10 years of war two years
of fullscale war waged by a war criminal
in the Kremlin the Ukrainian Nation
stands United and refuses to be
subjugated back into the servitude of
the Russian gulak the EU also stands
United behind Ukraine and we are not
alone if we look at the Ramstein format
of almost 50 states who help in
multifaceted ways I'm proud the standing
reporter for Ukraine and as a co-
rapporter for the Ukraine facility that
we concluded the trialogue on the
Ukraine facility yesterday evening as
part of the revised multiannual
Financial framework but we cannot forget
but we can forget about all these good
things that we have foreseen if Ukraine
is not enable to defend itself and push
back the aggressor towards its own
borders we need to support Ukraine in
this regard not only as long as it takes
but with whatever it takes and that is
why I support the suggestion of the
Estonian prime minister that said that
every EU member State should provide 0.0
25% of its GDP for weapons deliveries to
the country presid
maon president macron has spoken on
several occasions about France's support
up until Victory fine but French arms
need to be
supplied to the exem extent as German
arms are given the uh doubts of the um
German Chancellor we have a call on the
German bundesbank deliver tawus now
there's a majority in the bundus tank
for that Germany isn't a oneman
democracy don't be afraid of your uh
parties on the left let's face up to
Putin let's stand up against the empire
of the evil U which threatens our way of
life SL a ukraini speaker is Mr swen
mixer
please president dear colleagues two
years into Putin's war of aggression
against Ukraine what can be said one
thing is for sure Putin has failed his
Blitz Creek has failed miserably he has
not managed to break the resolve of
Brave Ukrainian soldiers Brave Ukrainian
people or of the democratic world that
continues to stand with Ukraine and
indeed somehow Mr Putin has even managed
to double the length of his country's
border with the NATO
alliance so Putin has failed but we are
yet to succeed we have said over and
over again that we would stand with
Ukraine for as long as it takes but let
us be clear how long it takes depends
directly on how much we give and how
quickly we do it so we must give more
and we have to do it now let me repeat
what I I have said from this stand
before if all of our member states and
all our transatlantic partners where to
Pledge on a sustainable basis just 1/4
of 1% of our GDP for the support of
Ukraine's war effort it would make a
crucial difference it would help to end
this war and hand the Russian aggressor
the decisive defeat it deserves and this
would be the best gift we could give to
our continent's future security and
prosperity thank you Mr mixa I shall ask
Natalie liso to come forward please sh
colleague
colleagues the European Summit of first
February was a success because it
confirmed our financial aid to Ukraine
but let's face it as far as our military
aid is concerned the summit was a
failure on several
counts the eighth trch of European
military aid has been blocked for months
because of
Hungary the future of a visible and
predictable European peace facility for
Ukraine is uncertain nothing has yet
been decided and above all no funding
has been
clarified instead of taking action and
making decisions our countries are
accusing each other of not doing enough
when they should all be doing more much
more and faster much faster the m
ammunition plan is not living up to its
promises 500,000 rounds of ammunition
delivered to Keef is half of what was
announced above all it's woefully
inadequate so please I appeal to All
European leaders for Ukraine for the
security of Europe you have a duty to
rise to the occasion and you've not yet
done
so
never forget failure is not an option
complacency is not a method slra next
speaker is M Alvina alamet
Please Mr President dear
colleagues about two years of war that's
two years too
much the Russian U attack on Ukraine is
an attack on Europe um the rule of law
and peace two years it's this the same
uh also a sign of the toughness of the
the ukrainians they have stood it out we
must
too the EU must increase its financial
and military aid uh to Ukraine so that
we they can
win F 50 billion euros in Aid is
important I demand that the
200 billion uh in frozen assets of the
Russian single single Central Bank
should be used in full uh for the
benefit of Ukraine we must train uh
soldiers in Ukraine and find out new
ways where what how we can help them
straight away two years about 200,000
ukrainians have died or been injured we
won't forget we won't give up SLA
ukraini thank you very much Miss Alam
next speaker is Vice President Robert
Zilla
please thank you
chair Madame
Minister Vice chair the good news for
Ukraine of course is is 50 billion
support but let's be honest the military
assist assistance from the member states
is not sufficient and we are late we are
late especially some member states are
hesitating we are not being able to deal
with the confiscation of the Seas
Russian assets the system has not been
uh perfect also for avoiding sanctions
and the EU businesses are still using
all kinds of export Commodities from the
Russian Russia and profit on that why am
I saying this because time is of essence
we cannot help Ukraine sometime in the
future for a certain amount we thus
endanger the nation of Ukraine the
language of Ukraine during this time the
rific russification aims are being um
achieved by Russia meanwhile we held
there was a prominent conference in
Regal last year against the genocide
um against the children in Ukraine that
are being the children that are being
stolen and taken away also during the
Soviet times Russia was implementing
this russification
um um attempts but they did not dist
ract children from the families but now
these children within two months could
lose their ties with Ukraine and
language and everything and if we want
to help them then time is of essence and
we can only help them by providing full
military assistance as soon as possible
so that we don't lose time and don't
lose the nation much vice president zela
next speaker is Mr and sprindale
V some
planning the mixture of f uh financial
assistance for the Ukrainian uh war and
uh the EU membership is
harmful uh we should shouldn't uh deny
things if the Ukraine becomes an EU
member it means more criminality more
social dumping more uh welfare tourism
for Denmark and alone the costs will be
6 to 6 26 billion every in every um
budget period uh 26 big hospitals that's
the equivalent so a it would be EU
membership for Ukraine will be a
disaster for us if we should help
Ukraine it should be weapons here and
now uh Denmark has provide uh more of
that than most of the member states here
and this
uh uh and this is all the more important
when you compare that with the prospect
of U Ukrainian membership of the
Ru
please thank you president two years
after Putin's invasion of Ukraine
and this war has
escalated leading to a numerous
negotiation project is the situation
better today have we closer to peace no
thousands of lives have been wasted
dependency on humanitarian Aid 4 million
people are displaced in the country we
have 6 million refugees outside Ukraine
a public debt of 90% and a 70% of GDP
debt to the IMF destruction of
infrastructure a destroyed political
system these consequences have reached
Europe too increased inflation Energy
prices food prices not everything has
been lost in these two years though the
US has doubled its export of gas to
Europe and it's companies uh seeing
multi-million dollar
profit the EU and this Parliament is
responsible for this too because our
only response to the conflict has been
to defend the US interests and not
European interests here enough this is a
failed
strategy uh when will we stop will we
give the US companies concessions to
reconstruct the country there is no time
to be lost here thank you there's a blue
card would you accept a blue card from
Mr bikov
please yes Mr bikov
please you advocated a whole lot of
anti-americanism I didn't expect
anything
else you advocated a whole lot of
anti-americanism here I didn't expect
anything else but are you not ashamed
that you speak on this topic without
mentioning with a single word the
responsibility of the Russian dictator
Putin for this War aren't you
ashamed seor
buer Mr
buer
we have
denounced in illegal interference of
Russia and Ukraine since the
outset but repeating a lie many times
doesn't make it more true I'll be honest
though what I find shameful is the
response of the European institutions
and this European Parliament where it
was promised that we would be taking
action for ukrainians but the only thing
we've done is finance a
war that is no longer on the front pages
in the media in a few months this will
no longer be on news reports but
millions of people will continue to be
displaced and their country has been
absolutely destroyed uh the EU has not
defended European interests here and we
need to invest in a just and sustainable
peace Andrea bkor
please thank you Mr Vice
President it's been two years years that
the war has been going on and we've only
been hearing empty phrases that we
support Ukraine as long as it is
necessary and then you continue living
your lives when you've left the
hemicycle you're trying to capitalize on
a personal tragedy where hundreds of
thousands of people have lost their
lives Millions have lost their homes and
they have to live the tragedy and horror
of war they by day young and old uh men
and women wake up to uh Sirens um and
they don't know when they're going to
lose their loved ones this is the side
of war that I see
um they're drafting soldiers and burying
them including among themselves ethnic
hungarians we need to put an end to this
we need peace we need peace talks uh a
lasting peace deal is the only solution
and you must end with your full lies
about Hungary we have said that we
support the territorial Integrity of
Hungary we have said it all along we
have also come out with negative
criticism about Russian uh Invasion we
support life future and peace next
speaker is Mr David McAllister
Please Mr President Madame Minister vice
president ladies and gentlemen dear
colleagues late in the evening yesterday
it was actually just before midnight we
concluded the trialogue on the Ukraine
facility we can now provide Ukraine with
predictable financing throughout
2024 and Beyond this is good news and I
would like to thank all colleagues
engaged in these procedures M Gala one
of the co- reporter is present with a
total of 50 billion EUR and by the way
dear Council dear commission
representatives to be complemented also
by the proceeds of Russian Frozen Act
assets the Ukraine facility gives us
maximum flexibility with regard to the
annual distribution of loans grants and
guarantees colleagues this agreement is
a vital step in our support of Ukraine
against the Russian
aggressor despite seeming Relentless
Russia is failing on multiple objectives
I can only underline what commission
president Osa ferine said in remarkably
clear words this war for Russia is
primarily a military failure Russia's
failure is also economic and finally
Russia's failure is also diplomatic
Ukraine can Prevail Victorious but we
must continue to empower their
resistance especially now that Russia is
stepping up its attacks on civilian
infrastructure trying to demoralize the
brave Ukrainian people in the EU we must
not lose sight of this sense of urgency
thank you thank you very much Mr
mallister next speaker is Mr wsh chimic
Please Mr chair it's been two years
since the fullscale Russian aggression
against Ukraine started it's been two
years of heroic defense of Ukraine and
Europe it's been two years of
unprecedented help for Ukraine and
ukrainians by the Democratic world but
it's also two years of Maneuvers by
opportunistic political leaders who have
done a lot not to let Russia be defeated
and have not done the right things in
the right time and that policy continues
with protecting aggressors frozen assets
against confiscation and using them to
support the victim it's a shame that
instead of confiscation misleading
formulas are invented offering to
Ukraine a fraction of what can be given
it's a shame that US Congress blocks
necessary arms and ammunition supplies
betraying Ukrainian soldiers facing
growing Russian pressure once again in
history it's a choice between law and
peace on the one hand and disgrace and
War on the other thank you thank you
very much dear colleague next speaker is
Miss Hilda vman
please thank you
colleas thank
you
colleagues the message sent by the
European Council last week was crystal
clear
support to Ukraine in the long term this
support is crucial but arms Munitions
need to get to LC Ukraine so that
Ukraine can Prevail with two years of
war it appears that in some countries
there's been more fine words than
delivery of
arms they need Munitions we need
action this is is the crucial point the
promises are easy you can promise
millions of Munitions but we need the
delivery they need to get there that's
the vital thing they still don't have
enough weapons to defend themselves and
it's too little too late in many ways
I'm terribly sorry to say we need to
have joint procurement of Defense
materials we need to strengthen the
European Defense industry and as I've
said before we need a European
Army former UK prime minister Winston
Churchill said in 1950 we need a
European Army the time has come for us
to do that
please president uh Madame commissioner
this is a very serious debate indeed I'm
uh very sorry to see that Mrs V is not
with us until the very end end of this
debate thank you very much for your
declarations and statements
words um are um not as expensive and
they are not as heavy as Deeds I don't
understand why aren't we making the
sanction sanction system more
watertight uh why is part of the West uh
still uh making deals with Russia I can
understand that we're talking about
Swiss Taiwanese or American companies
but we also have European companies in
this who are participating in this game
and thus assisting
Russia so
if a large part of
semiconductors that the Russian army
needs uh are exported from the West
towards Russia if Russian soldiers are
killing
ukrainians uh and they we uh western
boots we need to think about it long and
hard why is that
so at the farmer protest last week
outside the parliament a banner read you
promised peace you promised us
prosperity you've delivered war and
poverty why are we still facilitating
this senseless and bloody war in Ukraine
why did NATO block the peace deal that
we knew had about Ukrainian and Russian
backing in March
2022 for two years your decisions on
Ukraine are based on the idea that
Ukraine is going to win well it's not
looking great ziny said at the weekend
the war is in the stal may they have a
mobilization crisis conscription age has
been lowered to 25 videos bound of young
men being kidnapped off the streets and
forced to the front who's going to fight
your War corruption is off the charts
zilinski is about to sack his popular
commander-in Chief of the Armed Forces
ly and a raft of top government
officials the wheels are coming off the
war is crippling the EU you why on Earth
are we not making the aid conditional on
peace this is absolute Insanity what
time you C down to yourselves thank you
next speaker is Mr andreus kubilius
please dear
colleagues ukrainians for two years with
a lot of sacrifice defend not only their
country but also all of us includ
cluding Mr Wallace the victory of
Ukraine depends on our political will to
deliver what is needed for victory
ukrainians are not failing with their
bravery and
sacrifice We are failing with our
assistance our assistance during those
two years allowed Ukraine not to lose a
war but it was too short for the victory
let's remember last year Russia managed
to spent for its War more than 100
billion euros and Ukrainian side with
all our assistance had only 80 billion
EUR all the EU military assistance
during last year reached less than 1 uh
0.1% of EU
GDP we do not look serious with such
numbers the problem is that all our
assistance depends on individual
voluntary decision of each member State
how much to support such an arrangement
does not produce enough of support we
have example of our Collective approach
they European union plan for ammunition
delivery despite its shortcomings it is
a good example how EU needs to act we
need to have the EU plan for the victory
of Ukraine which would cover all the
military needs of Ukraine not only
artillary shells such a plan should
start from the obligation of each member
state to deliver military assistant not
less than 0.25% of national uh GDP like
s mixer have said before for it would
allow to significantly increase military
production both in Ukraine and in EU
that is how Ukraine would start to
Prevail Victor of Ukraine is needed for
us and let's make it Slava Ukraine thank
you very much Mr kilius next speaker is
Mr tonino
Pula thank you Mr President dear
colleagues our support for Ukraine is an
important as it was on the day one of
the Russian aggression though the
situation at the battlefield is a
stalemate European Union has proven that
is will be forged in the crisis as Jean
Monet said just see the collective
defense efforts energy Imports and
sanctions but we need to do more the
council's decision last week is a strong
message from the European Union in all
directions to Ukraine which is fighting
for freedom to Russia which counted on
the fatigue of the EU with the war and
perhaps on its General collapse but also
to Washington that European Union
doesn't give up its efforts for Kev and
as the United States must also overcome
internal divisions and to continue
supporting Ukraine with this decision
European Union engagement gains new
momentum in this super election year
European Union should confirm at a
global level that it's still a relevant
significance Slava
ukraini Merc
P thank you Mr Pula I now give the floor
to Mr Berard geta
colleagues he thought he'd be entering
Kev in three days and what's the
situation now two years on and Putin
controls only 17.5% of Ukrainian
territory and he's not even able to
maintain control of the Black Sea in
Crimea this is referred to as a defeat
but how do we help the ukrainians to
turn this into a
victory well our 27 leaders must decide
to tell our Nations that we are at War
we're not about to march on Moscow but
we're fighting a war for the freedom of
our peoples and stability on our
continent and this war demands serious
sacrifices a common defense and that
we drum up determination to win we're
not able to do this without our voters
really knowing who stands with who so
you on the far right come out and say it
whose side are you really on on Putin's
or on that of
Freedom this is the only condition for a
Ukrainian
Victory because the enemy Bears none of
the homeworks of an invincible Force
no two
years two years since the aggressive
attack of Putin's horde on Ukraine yes
part of our society and probably part of
of our politicians are getting tired of
the fact that we're dealing with what is
happening in Ukraine and the
consequences for Europe but fatigue is
not the solution if we don't stop Russia
now it'll be someone else's turn next
time and the consequences will be much
worse for all of us that is why we must
persevere in supporting Ukraine's heroic
struggle and we must also address all
the things that we have neglected over
the past decades 2% of the defense
budget must be the absolute minimum for
any member State and we must finally get
our defense industry into production
it's not possible for banks to refuse to
finance investment in the defense
industry that cannot be we as Europe
have not been able to produce enough
ammunition we still have a lot of work
to do but we have no alternative there
is no Third Way Ukraine must
Prevail and the EU must Prevail with
Ukraine is Mr Francisco
joseon thank you
president these are several years of an
illegal and cruel War fought by Russia
against Ukraine we will continue to
support this Brave country this is a war
of attrition where the supply of
ammunition is fundamental Russians are
using projectiles in a much greater
quantity than the ukrainians five times
more but they
persist the Russian Munitions
production um industry is making
advanage and that is worrying as we
heard during the second world war the
European Union must be an Arsenal for
democracies Everybody Must contribute to
military support we've seen recently
that military support from France Italy
Spain did not go beyond 20 0 million EUR
if we want to help Ukraine we need to
support the European Defense
industry especially because we know who
will be taking the White House in 10
months last week we gave the green light
to additional Aid to
Ukraine and I hope that Washington will
do the same and promptly unblock
financing for Ukraine thank you next AR
is here Yen next speaker yens
gy
sh thank you very much president vice
president shev kovich colleagues it's
almost two years now that Putin is uh
Waging War in Europe against the
Ukrainian people and its freedom it's
two years too uh much but our message is
clear we support Ukraine as long as
Putin requires us to I'd like to thank
Chancellor Schultz that he made it
possible to um um have invited Victor
Orbin for a cup of coffee the German
government is
not not just been attacked by the EP
here that the German the German
contribution to Ukraine was too small
it's always been insufficient but it's
important to note that no other state in
the EU is doing any more to support the
defensive capabilities of Ukraine than
my request to you would be
colleagues make sure that your
governments redouble their
efforts this also
includes
institutionally not having unanimity in
foreign and um uh security decisions in
the EU that would be the uh main way to
um face up to
blackmailers within and also for Ukraine
to be able to stand up for his
sovereignty next thank you Mr D is the
next
speaker thank you chair vice president
dear Minister dear colleagues this
horrendous war on our continent was not
supposed to last that long Putin thought
it would be quick we thought Ukraine
wouldn't stand this ground and most
thought our driving solidarity as a
union wouldn't last either but here we
are in a reality where everyone was
wrong in their initial planning except
Ukraine
and his brave people who believed in
their cause from day one who fought and
died every single of these 700 days
today our task must be Crystal Clear
Ukraine's resilience is nonnegotiable
our peace is no longer a natural given
right and for both of these reasons we
must equip our Union with what it takes
to become a credible long-term security
provider an articulated defense
industrial Vision instruments to deliver
it and the defense commissioner to keep
all this together and now in the
immediate term we must put our money and
weapons where our political mouth is
that is how Ukraine can win this war
thank you thank you Mr K next speaker is
Mr Dominic tar
chinski thank you Mr President dear
leftists it's been two years two years
of Putin's attack and what have you
done nothing what have you done Mr
as a Germany what have you done 5,000
helmets that's your achievement oh no
you build a North stream to and then you
block the sanctions that is the fact
What About Belgium you you are
responsible for blocking sanctions on on
Russian diamonds when we polish
government conservative government was
fighting for it what about Austria
Austria was blocking 12 12th package of
sanctions because one of their Banks was
on the list of the war sponsors what
about the
rest all you did was just a blocking
sanctions and Poland was first to help
when Russians attacked 17 million people
crossed polish Ukrainian border so do
not lecture us about Humanity about aums
about refugees because we do know what
the refugee is and what illegal migrant
is I was the first MEP to see massive
Graves how many of you visited your
ukine how many of you visited lampeduza
I was the one to see illegal migrants so
let's make a deal you take illegal
migrants we're going to take those who
were attacked thank very much next
speaker is Mr Lucas
Mandel than thank you president
colleagues it's important and correct
that the
EU support the the ukrainians in their
fight for survival it's existential for
the EU for Europe for the whole free
world and 2024 will show that the
EU must do this independently it's also
important what the commission president
said on the 1st of March
2022 immediately after the start of the
war in our extraordinary sitting at the
European Parliament that we must reach
out and to the other uh Russia but we
don't know the other Russia no face no
name and 2024 won't give us that we must
stand together we must stand behind
Ukraine the people in Ukraine mustn't
have any uh illusions that it will end
quickly or there'll be a rapid EU
membership Ukraine will be free Europe
will be free democra Democratic with the
the rule of law and every effort makes
that
worthwhile for two years now Ukraine has
been defending its territory and
citizens against Putin's illegitimate
attack very
bravely Russia has threatened not only
security and stability in Europe but our
values of peace and democracy
underpinning Europe
Putin thought that Ukraine would have
collapsed in on itself but the people
with Firm support from Europe have not
allowed that from day one the EU
institutions have stood side by side
with the Ukrainian resistance in
tangible form 80 billion and financial
humanitarian and Military Support the EU
decided to stand up and defend democracy
not leave Ukraine at the mercy of an
unscrupulous dictator such as PU Putin
although some sovereigntist
leaders friendly with the Italian
leadership wanted to block resources
it's not enough to uh defend the people
of Europe we have to defend rule of law
in Europe some still think that they can
undermine freedom and the rights of
people and others are in different
colleagues due to the delay I will not
take any more blue cards and I also will
close the request for catdi and we will
continue with Mr jiz dski
please thank you very much chair when
two years ago Russia launched its attack
large scale attack on Ukraine Europe was
shocked shaken uh although the brutal
Russian imperialism has been known in
Europe for centuries it would have been
good to uh look into history and know
more about it ukrainians surprised us by
their determination and courage but
today sentiments and feelings are
different and we must not forget about
that and this is also our fault Ukraine
is uh solely missing not only equipment
but also people the willingness of young
ukrainians to go and fight is decreasing
they prefer to stay abroad and uh
political uh rif is growing in uh Kiev
we need to do more in this context
rather than less it is very important
that the European Council decided to
support our help to Ukraine and that
they finally decided to think about the
use of Frozen Russian assets I would
like to congratulate us on this
determination and let us hope that we
will not have to wait two more years for
specific action concrete action in this
respect
mer thank you president dear vice
president two years
ago Russian troops
invaded Kev they invaded
Ukraine Vladimir Putin was
clear he wanted the
Europe controlled by Moscow from Kev to
Lisbon this desire on Putin's part has
not
changed and therefore it is crucial two
years on that the European Union be on
the Frontline of solidarity with the
Ukrainian State and the Ukrainian people
financial support is
crucial Military Support is crucial
humanitarian support is crucial and it
is fundamental that we move forward with
Ukraine's accession
process we must must link Ukraine to
Nato without these pillars financial
support humanitarian support Military
Support integration into the EU and
integration into NATO Europe will be
weaker it will be vulnerable and Putin
and the Russian Invaders will have won
Mr Rangel next speaker is Mr Ty
Ren thank you president dear commission
Council colleagues yes yes the EU showed
Unity last week with the Ukraine
facility in support of the Brave
ukrainians fighting also on our behalf
for our democracy but make no mistake
Orban held the other 26 hostage for way
too long and it is an illusion to think
he will stop he delayed and blackmailed
you into unlawfully unfreezing 10
billion euros sort it use article 7
suspend the presidency because other
rats will never stop unless we stop them
Putin will not stop either unless we
give Ukraine the military support it
needs to win not just what it needs not
to lose but the differences in bilateral
military aid by member states are
inexplicable and frankly unacceptable
send the ammunition send the Jets send
the at camps Ukraine must be able to
neutralize Russian positions from where
it is attacked Ukraine must win Slava
ukraina
yes thank you uh thank you very much Mr
Ro next speaker is Mr Alexander
aland thank
you president I should say that I really
welcome the agreement in the European
Council to continue to support Ukraine
in all
areas this deter
mination should continue till Russian
aggressors have been chased away we need
determined action Russia should really
be made to experience the whole horror
of the war that it started Russia should
be totally
isolated Perhaps it is time to think
about putting a stop to any diplom Matic
relations with Russia because according
to the convention these relations should
be based on friendship and
cooperation however we cannot have
relations of
cooperation and friendship with Putin
we're not
Oran it's clear that we should also be
led by principles values and morality
slav
ukraini thank you I shall now give the
floor to Rafael
glesman thank you
colleagues we thought that Europe
had woken up two years ago from our
sance stuper in Europe we thought our
eyes were open now but
unfortunately the Sleep Walkers are
still in their Perpetual lethargy for 2
years
now how is it possible that the 200
billion Euro Russian money Frozen in our
banks should not have been seized
yet what about the lack of Munitions for
the Ukrainian forces we've been
promising that we will use what we can
save to support that War uh effort we're
looking at 10,000 per day uh supplied to
the front which is pathetic we say that
we will support Ukraine we say that we
will show
solidarity
but it's actually real politic and
self-interest in dbass and Crimea it was
a different issue this is against Europe
itself this is against us
but that alarm call has not been heeded
sluk Mr GL next speaker is Miss yolan go
please thank you very much dear
president I welcome the recent decision
of the European Council to Grant a to
Ukraine and the conclusion of a
trialogue which happened yesterday here
in
Parliament and the Ukraine has bravely
sustained many sacrifices for the
Ukraine to be able to go on the path of
its European F future we are very well
aware as creations of the fight that
that's required for democracy and our
values with President tman we faced many
obstacles and the lack of support of the
then weak Europe Croatia was able to
defend not only itself but prevent
further massacre in Bosnia heroina and
also bring about the dayon Accord and
the peaceful reintegration of the area
around the danu although there have
been many suspicions as to whether that
could be
achieved we have fought against
autocratic regimes and those
who think that Putin will have a smooth
path towards achieving its OB its
objectives are wrong so don't
let history judge us because we're being
conformist thank you Coles we are having
a very important debate here so I ask
the colleagues entering the room not to
engage into conversations and um take a
seat please next speaker is Mr ero H
Lu Russia's brutal attack on Ukraine
continues with its attack the Russian
leadership has abandoned all the
country's principal commitments and
placed itself outside normal European
and international cooperation the
Ukrainian people are fighting heroically
for their self-determination but also
for the freedom of all
Europeans our task is to support Ukraine
with everything we have the European
Union must help by Financial
humanitarian and Military means the
Russian leadership must realize that
they will be held responsible for their
war of aggression and human rights
violations they will have to make good
all the destruction and all the damage
they are guilty of in Ukraine Ukraine is
fighting in difficult and challenging
conditions our promise of a European
connection European union membership is
important in showing the way for Ukraine
we understand the difficult conditions
of war and we also trust that membership
the EU membership will path will help
Ukraine to make the necessary reforms
commit to democracy and citizens
freedoms and a society free of
corruption very much next speaker is Mr
Tomas sovi
thank you Mr
chair
V these are names of European CI cities
and we learned how to pronounce these
names correctly bit by bit because these
are cities where atrocities were were
committed by the Russian army rape
murder
aggression this shows what Putin's
regime is it threatens not just Ukraine
but European democracy as a whole ladies
and gentlemen for two years we have been
talking we've been saying that we need
to support Ukraine let us finally do
something time is running out and the
time for talking is over it is time for
action and we have to show Ukraine that
we stick to our word and that we count
on Ukraine as a future member of the
European Union Marina
curant uh thank you president vice
president Council
colleagues I have three key messages one
the war in Ukraine must come to an end
by a victory for Ukraine and under
Ukraine's
conditions Putin and his cronies all the
war criminals must face responsibility
for their actions it is only thus that
we will be able to stop this criminal
Onslaught and show that international
law prevails
to it's an excellent decision to
allocate these resources to Ukraine but
it's not enough all member states need
to increase their bilateral support to
Ukraine too if Estonia can do
it and give 1.5% of GDP why can't
everyone
else
solidarity it
is expensive to wage
war but what about the loss of life
which is the alternative the loss of
Ukrainian lives the EU May sometimes be
bureaucratic drag its feet but last week
we saw that the EU can
unanimously Provide support for Ukraine
dear ukrainians you have friends here
lelk you Mr
President $7,000
7 712 uh that's as many days as have
passed since the attack of Russia on
Ukraine this is an unprecedented attack
upon a free sovereign state which
started really 10 years ago when the
when Putin's Empire decided to take over
Crimea Don and Hans uh we see where at
leads us as we negotiate with an
aggressor this was an attack attack uh
upon Europe Upon Our continent upon a
fight against our love of Freedom
ukrainians are still proving that they
have opted for the European way of
living rather than the Russian peace as
it is called uh ourselves as the
European Union need to maintain and live
the memory of what happens if we
contribute to evil and to the ACT of the
evil forces have how evil can change the
world we must never ever forget this in
Europe we must not NE we must never Tire
fighting against evil Slava
ukraini next speaker is Mr um teras Rio
please thank you vice president dear
colleagues not a day goes by without
Russia CA causing death and pain all
across Ukraine two years of fullscale
war on European
soil Europe has moved slowly very slowly
from Igor State of Mind to the state of
alert I believe it has been a very
costly lesson the council decision
regarding 50 billion Aid package last
week was a much much appreciated
Lifeline for Ukraine but we need more
it's merely one sixth of what Ukraine
needs in the coming four
years the war this particular War cannot
be won by sending obsolete military
equipment to Ukraine but military
technological Supremacy and that cost
money therefore Estonia calls for
initiative of 2.25
0.25% of the GDP allocated for Ukraine
which equals 120 billion euros military
aid
annually together we can out power the
aggressor I have no doubt about it this
is for our own security and for our own
way of life
ukra thank you very much and we're now
coming to the catdi and I have too many
speakers unfortunately on my list so
I'll be I'll take them uh to the order
as they asked the floor as they pushed
the button to request the catdi and I
will take uh uh two of um each group if
there is two speakers per group so the
first one is Mikela shova
please ladies and
gentlemen
Ukraine has shown great persistence in
its Fight For Freedom thousands of young
men have died but they will not be
forgotten um as well as hundreds of
athletes who have defended their country
who have been killed or injured and who
will not be able to participate in the
Olympic Games we know their faces and I
hope that at least their photos will be
shown symbolically in
Paris it is unacceptable that their
assassins can participate in the Olympic
Games and that is why we are appealing
to Banning Russian participation let us
not forget yet the thousands of children
too who were brought to Russia for
russification we will
continue to work towards their
repatriation Russia has no right to
steal
children we must show greater
willingness to help Ukraine so that
their victims are not lost in vain
graas thank you president on the 24th of
February it will be the 2-year
anniversary of this unfair cruel
Invasion that put Ukraine and the EU
under unprecedented pressure but it has
also
shown our institutions solidarity and
strength this new agreement the Ukraine
facility the uh 50 billion up to
2027 will allow us to better meet the
needs for reconstruction and postwar
modernization this should go to the
different regions of Ukraine and those
who are responsible for
reconstruction local and Regional
administrations as well as National
administrations need to be at the heart
there we need to give them the help they
need but don't forget the funding really
needs to get to those who need it most
it has to be a sustainable inclusive
reconstruction speaker is Miss Emma
visner we have done too little to
support Ukraine I'm embarrassed that our
colleagues in Kiev are sat there waiting
uh to see what mood Victor Orban is in
today to see if they will get support
from the EU leadership or not we have
done too little and we must do more
Ukraine deserves
long-term and stable support from the
whole of the European Union and this
must be done as long as it takes every
country must guarantee to deliver
support as long as the war continues
thank you thank you very much next
speaker is Miss CLA
Daly before Russia invaded Ukraine NATO
was in terminal decline the SC of
European moral superiority wasn't
working a spent Force discredited by
Decades of illegal Wars Iraq Libya
Afghanistan and then Along Came Russia
and took the bait and the whole sorry
Saga went down the memory hole European
leaders parading around chanting about
Glory draped in Flags pretending to care
about democracy and international law
while slobbering over arms contract
it's easy to see why you'd want the war
to go on but it's over and while you're
amusing yourselves with your pantomine
church Al act Ukraine is running out of
men and running out of Hope as European
economies tanks few believe that Victory
is around the corner even the White
House is backing off and your support
for Israel shows you never cared about
democracy it's about handouts to Arms
companies and the might of the
US
okay no sorry
sorry can yeah Mr radan
canv it'sing it that's not
working no
508 thank you thank you
uh it's it's two years after the start
uh of the fulls scale invasion of Russia
in Ukraine but it's also 10 years after
the illegal occupation of Crimea and let
me remind you it's exactly 20 years
after the poisoning of President yusenko
of Ukraine and I think 20 years later
even the so-called useful idiots in this
hemicycle must clearly see the
intentions of the Imperial regime in the
Kremlin but even more importantly it
must be clear what our pragmatic
interest as Nations and United Europe is
and it is that defending the
independence and the internationally
recognized borders of Ukraine is the
interest of our own National Security
and furthermore that isolating Russia
economically is our clear interest of
our economic independence you know a lot
of Russian propagandist say Russia
doesn't like meddling in its backyard
but in the Imperial mentality in Kremlin
their backyard includes not only sofhia
and Bucharest but also Berlin and Moscow
thank
you the last speaker is Mr yasas
OAS thank you president dear
colleagues we are grateful to ukrainians
for defending our values and the future
of our children against the Russian
aggression it was really shameful where
for two year for two months we could not
agree on support to Ukraine today we
have a decision on the 50 billion
facility of Ukraine but we all
understand it's too little colleagues
have mentioned that we are not using the
300 billion uh of Frozen Russian
assets our sanctions are not effective
enough
another shameful almost legal trade is
200 billion of trade with Russia some
Ukrainian lithian experts proposed to
the commission to uh Levy a war tax on
this illegal trade and I would like to
invite the council to consider this very
much and um now the floor uh goes back
to the commission and I see it's a
Commission Executive Vice President
sovich
please thank you very much Mr President
Madame Minister honorable members I'm
sure that we all vividly remember our
extraordinary session of plenary in
Brussels taking place few days after
Russian invasion in Ukraine
and I recall our common shock and horror
that after long Decades of Peace War has
returned back to
Europe as you recall we've listened to
the video Ling address of President
zalinski and have been impressed by his
determination to fight the Invaders to
defend the liberty and sovereignity of
his country I believe that that was that
moment when these unbreakable bonds
between European union and and Ukraine
was firmly
established at that time we couldn't
imagine the level of human suffering the
scale of tragic loss of lives and
destruction brought by War at that time
we couldn't imagine neither The Bravery
of Ukrainian people but also the level
and strength of European solidarity
unity and resilience we couldn't expect
the rapid enlargement of NATO and the
Vigor of enlargement process where
Ukraine mova Georgia and Western Balan
countries are now firmly on the PA to
become the EU member states the decision
of the European Council on the 15
billion EUR of Ukrainian facility which
we discussed at the previous debate
confirms that the EU will stay shoulder
to shoulder with Ukraine and ukrainians
and that we will do that as long as it
takes and this debate honorable members
sends another strong message of support
and solidarity to Ukraine and for that I
really would like to thank
you Minister L you have the
flooor vice president commissioner
chich honorable members of the European
Parliament since the Russian aggression
Ukraine has shown
unflinching resistance they deserve our
admiration and respect for
that throughout this conflict the EU has
shown itself to be the closest Ally of
Ukraine providing unprecedented levels
of support both in terms of content and
scope I had the opportunity to talk
about that in my earlier speech of
course the scope for
improvement we need to take account of
the effect on our internal Market some
of you have spoken about Farmers
unhappiness we need to look at what kind
of flexibility and adaptability will be
necessary we have unwavering support for
Ukraine for as long as it takes we need
to make that very clear the recent
extraordinary Summit of the 1 of uh
February shows that the European Council
is willing to follow through but we need
to do more and we need to be active on
several fronts delivering Munitions
first and foremost that needs to speed
up the Ukraine facility is an area
where Parliament and Council need to
develop the agreement of principle
achieved last night we are at your
disposal to sit with Parliament to
discuss the mff to reach an agreement as
soon as possible Military Support the
European Council IL asked Council to
come to an agreement by the beginning of
March last week for a
specific fund for Ukraine and the work
has started on that a new sanctions
package is currently being prepared for
the symbolic date of the 24th of
February and I take this opportunity to
tell you that the 12th sanctions package
will include diamonds it's already taken
effect and Belgium has worked on the
preparation of a mechanism that will
allow us to invoid any circumvention of
those uh sanctions specifically thanks
to involvement of G7 states combating
circumvention of sanctions is one of our
top priorities we're engaged in
Awareness raising with third countries
David as Sullivan as a special Envoy has
been working on this too and we've also
been working on the companies of those
third countries we've already seen some
of the results of this in certain
countries and will continue supporting
Ukraine and sanctioning Russia for as
long as it takes to conclude I can State
once again that the future of Ukraine
the future of the citizens of Ukraine is
lies in the heart of Europe we will not
abandon
[Music]
them thank you very much Minister the
debate is closed the vote will take
place at the next session end it for a
few moments and it will resume with the
votes very very
soon